hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
Pandora's you know making a revolution
routine presented by dr. Shane McKee
clinical director at belfast i'm susie
valdez of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
excited to bring you this educational
virtual conference presented by lab Lutz
the leading scientific social networking
website and provider a virtual event and
webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning
here's how this presentation will work
today we want to hear from you
the questions comments and even answers
can be submitted in the green Q&A button
at the lower left of your screen we'll
try to get to everyone but if not we'll
make sure to follow up with you by email
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button in the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CC
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I'd
like to now introduce today's wonderful
speaker dr. Shane McKee me welcome sir
so much owned a place to be able to join
you and a
cherylin bit of the journey that we've
been taking here in Belfast by trying to
apply genomics and routine clinical
practice it's really quite exciting
the developments that we've experienced
over the past number of years but I
think one of the difficulties we've had
is what I term making the left shift of
genetics and genomics into making this
much more routine so my name is Susie is
said is Shane McKee I'm a consultant in
clinical genetics here in Belfast in
Northern Ireland and day-out practice
really involves a most lots of patients
that are referred to this from lots of
different specialties so people who may
be and at the very start of life and
even towards the end of life so fully
into patients on day some very
interesting conditions but what we try
to do is to make up useful for patients
those are moving forward like when I'm
still alive in genetics a number of
years ago this is a picture of me and my
in my role as a clinical geneticist on
the globe my colleagues from pediatrics
and from a pediatric neurology and a
number of other specialties in the back
here looking very suspiciously on some
of the things that I'm trying to get up
to and our traditional a modus operandi
was to see a patient who'd be referred
to us I'm going to try to use the clues
that were provided to us either from the
original medical records that the
patient came along with or from asking
the patient questions or from examining
the patient of carrying out a number of
investigations to get towards a clinical
diagnosis what as this patient got along
with them and for a number of years they
one of the ways that we did that was we
would test the individual genes that we
knew would be associated with a certain
thing so for example if we saw a child
that we thought like they had Down
syndrome with the chromosome test I'm
going to verify it as an extra
chromosome 21 therefore with [ __ ]
diagnosis that way Arkansas child
Williams syndrome would carry out a
deletion screen for chromosome number 7
and we find
a relation associated with thought and
some of our numbers of other genes as we
moved forward but during that process I
think really as a result of that process
one of the issues that we find was this
is this can be quite expensive
particularly if we get it wrong and I'm
not quite sure what they the pricing
structure is for genetic tests in the US
but many of these genes would be upwards
of maybe and it could've really fifteen
hundred dollars or something to test one
particular gene and I think that would
be what we to come back to the health
system so there were lots of expensive
clinical diagnostic tests that we would
have to use and other law techniques
would also be quite expensive and would
maybe have people through one particular
exon of a gene so there's 20,000 genes
and we're having to look through under
each gene that has an average of ten
exons and you're doing that one of the
time that soon becomes very expensive
and very very time-consuming so it
wasn't a lot of fun on a certain extent
then when we would walk into the
neonatal unit or something again like
the gentleman and this a photograph and
we would find that they are meet on
piano would stop playing and everyone
would turn around and shift awkwardly so
this is what and I come to refer here as
the left shift paradox how do we move
this what is sometimes perceived to be
very very arcane and very specialized
information into an earlier part of the
patient's diagnostic process so we want
to make these diagnoses of what very
often are very rare diseases early in
the patient's journey so we can then
manage their treatment their general
knowledge and further investigations who
else they have to see as we move forward
so the paradox effectively is this the
diagnosis is very often made towards the
end of our journey whenever they see the
appropriate specialist but the problem
for the position or the healthcare
professional that comes into contact
with the family and the first place is
to know which I highly specialized
physician or a diagnostician
to refer the patient on to so unless you
get the right person first timelines
you may not make the diagnosis so one of
the issues that we've tried to do is
clinical genetics uh basically you can I
know certainly in the US and Canada and
elsewhere is to have a system of people
who are almost specialists and very
highly specialized rare diseases but
general enough to spot them when they're
coming from lots of different directions
but basically the problem is that
getting our connection registries
difficult and when we were and back in
the olden days doing our genetics
invasion there's I mean 10 15 years ago
we live great use of databases such as
the London was mythology database which
is a nurse created another usually
called the Oxford did this but London is
Noah and the designee home for this in
fact it even moves on past not but the
nor was that we would take these
features the phenotypic features into
the did this on the give this would come
back with the answer and that will tell
you what the patient had and this is a
discussion I used to have quite a lot
with my colleagues in the utility and in
pediatric urology that it maybe wasn't
quite as simple as that
but the databases that we had went very
very useful to teaching for teaching us
about different syndromes and different
conditions weren't nary not good
actually pulling out the diagnosis so
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done before you get to a diagnosis and
part of the reason is this now if you
put in any particular syndrome feature
so any particular things such as short
stature what you'll find is that there's
836 syndromes listed in that iteration
of the database with short stature as a
feature so it's not a very specific
feature mental retardation was much much
worse certainty not nearly free and it
syndromes with mental retardation of the
feature it's very difficult to a to use
even if you combine a lot of these
features together you find that there's
it's still difficult to be precise so
what I did in this particular graph
you'll see him getting a little a little
arrow up here but we can see that here
there's no me right and we've got a
number of syndromes that are very very
large numbers
I'm sorry the number of teachers and
very large numbers syndrome associated
with them and as we move down to the
bottom we find that there are other
syndromes which many only have one or
two features associated with them and it
works the other way around as well let's
try a shot and move on so if we look at
the number of features of different
syndromes have even quite a relatively
common conditions like kabuki syndrome
and or rare conditions very rare
conditions with castello syndrome which
are we won several tens of thousands how
not some of the syndromes associated
with them so if you use a database
approach even with quite good machine
learning technology it's very difficult
to know about dying of the nega
diagnosis now recently what has happened
is that a number of companies have been
involved in using facial recognition
technology to try and diagnose syndromes
that way and that's been very very
successful and we use a system by a
company called the FDA or face to gene
I'm find out very useful for a number of
different syndromes but again we need to
get referred to the specialist who then
has to do the cast or has to do the
photographic analysis etc to help make
your diagnosis I mean then you've still
got to come and confirm a diagnosis as
we move forward so why do we want the
bag nose in the first kiss and that
there may be an argument that well these
conditions are extremely rare and really
all you need to do is to sort of say oK
you've got a rare diagnosis then we'll
move on that don't you don't need to do
anything else and of course that's not
good enough any of us who are here
involved with patient and management at
any level and that includes direct from
a laboratory side to end the clinic we
know that the patients need to get a
diagnosis and there are a number of
different reasons for this and one is
that the patient's themselves may wish
to understand the condition they want to
know why it happens we want to know what
the mean is fourth and that's the
patient and the family and then want to
have a more accurate knowledge of the
prognosis so - slow to change
as time goes on
and they want no one in fact we all want
to know are there any ways that we can
potentially treat these conditions and
sometimes as well even just from the
quantity of community can we contact
other people who have the same condition
just to share our experience a to form a
bit of a bigger Lobby good for a
pressure group but particularly in a
many conditions of wheat as we find
recently is that if you can get a number
of patients together they can very often
form a very powerful patient advocacy
group advocating for research and for
further treatment for better management
in general so that's contact with other
people with the same condition even if
it's extremely rare and even if it
involves a patient for example in
Belfast getting into contact with a
patient in San Diego or something we've
we have situations like that involved in
all the time it can be extremely useful
so problem shared is a problem hard for
the wider family we may want to know
what are the chances of this condition
arising again if the if a couple for
example going to have another child will
a child at the same set of problems as
the first child and is there any
screening that we can bring into there
to maybe prevent the condition occurring
in the first place and prenatal testing
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis lots
of different possibilities and these
will influence them a couple of
reproductive decisions as to whether
they will have more children or not and
I guess an important point with this is
the faster we're going to get that
diagnosis the more likely we are to give
answer to a couple within the
reproductive time window because if we
leave this to live it may will be as a
couple of past reproducing and you know
they don't have any options left open
thinking about it and of course we don't
want to believe in these things going on
for a long period of time we want to get
these families answers all the time
whenever they become more useful for
them
the third option at the bottom there as
well just for medical research and many
of the genes that we know about in many
of the common conditions that we
investigate we know a lot more but then
because of rare versions of those
conditions best example of this might be
hyperlipidemia
which is getting us a lot of insights
into the cosmic causation of heart
attacks and the general population so
rare diseases can very often act as a
window into common diseases so so far so
good
and just mentioned in a slide the
potential for some of the treatment that
has been very hyped at the moment and
actually I personally feel that the
crisper cast 9 which is the very precise
gene editing technology which has
recently been very much in the news is a
very very powerful technique potentially
for the treatment for a lot of genetic
diseases so I think we in the genetics
community and most of you will be very
well wherever's are looking with extreme
interest with what we may be able to do
with a with CRISPR cast 9 in human cells
and for treatment of human disease
I've actually been some work done on
this and I think one of the big reasons
I guess for getting our precise
diagnosis is that we can then start to
formulate these these ideas of the time
we make using these new technologies
towards a towards development treatment
so this example and that have flashed up
here is for treatment of a urea cycle
defects or a severe metabolic conditions
and I guess the cautionary tale here is
that we find that even crisper castmates
this is from sense translational
medicine back again back last year 2016
the researchers were able to correct the
defect in sales but when they then moved
out into the nominal models have
actually proved fatal and the animal
models because the world metabolism of
the animals couldn't cope with it so we
really need to be extremely careful of
applying these technologies and I think
we've known this for a very long time
you can't just fix the gene and expect
everything to come along after these
where conditions are complex conditions
they're not they're not simple and
anything in medicine it's never simple
but that's whether we need to be just
very careful in how you proceed ahead
and one thing is give us a lot of hope
at least on the diagnostic side has been
the plummeting cost of actually carrying
it genetic and genomic analysis since is
a slide that again many of you would
have seen it's been plastered across the
news media it's in journals and articles
all the time but basically shows what
the cost of genome screening has
actually gone down very very
dramatically and in the past number of
years so we have for example and see
them again and back and whatever we
started testing genomes back in a
conversa 2000 whenever the first drop of
the human genome was produced and the
best mid live here 100 million US
dollars but the whole program probably
took about 3 to 3 billion dollars to
deliver so the way I like to experience
the medical students is that in the
course of the number of years since then
every two years we've basically not to
zero off the end about there which is is
quite spectacular
it means the genome sequencing costs
have fallen other way up it's actually a
good deal faster than Moore's law for
the trans industry that's where the
number of process or the number of
transistors you can put onto a microchip
doubles every 18 months or so so you
speed up the chip twice as much every 18
months and since a lover it looks feel
here and as you can see on the diagram
the this Moore's Law is going down but
actually the course of genome sequencing
has gone going much much further than
that
and my surrender at night it's
plateauing a little bit I don't know
about the yes
$1000 level so when I have the level
where we're talking realistically about
the $1,000 genome I'm not to go to sweet
spot because that means that this is not
within the realm of routine diagnostic
services so this would thing we like to
see we say we've got to a point where
this becomes becomes very very tractable
and the genome starts politically and a
very reasonable thing to talk about
actually sequencing on a routine
clinical basis
that hasn't quite happened yet but at
the same time if you'd told me ten years
ago that would be where we are right now
I would've thought that was pretty on my
gate so these are definitely moving
forward in a very exciting way I'm part
of the difficulty I guess that this is
then that was what is what I call this
infernal hierarchy mere victims of our
own history in many ways so what
happened back in the days where we could
just test single genes wasn't just
testing single genes and as we put it
our sequencing technology and we've got
these two Sanger sequencing being done
but passe and we're using
next-generation sequencing we've moved
on the panels of genes so for example
this panel from Oxford is set of 57
genes with some not as its dominant exon
basis and then just a black guy again
when we can test 57 genes that are known
to be involved in familial a taxes all
in one go and then get the results back
from that and that makes an awful lot of
sense whenever you're dealing with
phenotypes such as something like a
ataxia but is and that we know what is
caused by a large number of different
genes and clearly these can be very
difficult to tease apart so it makes
sense to test a large number of genes I
can get the stage now where this this
particular panel cost about I think to
the 1,200 UK Pines so rather than $1,500
or so on the next evolution on for not
on again this is largely historical is
moving on to a clinical exome or we
sequence all the genes that we know
about that cause clinical phenotypes
early into 11 patient house and we menus
on men to things like a whole exome
screen so again we're just testing the
genes themselves the protein coding
elements not the bits in between
yeah I've mentioned excellent trios here
so when we talk about our $1,000 genome
that's fine for one individual patient
but effort talking about testing a child
for example we're using cognitive
testing with child
plus the parents so we can compare the
genome of the child with the genome of
the parents and this is a very powerful
technique for a large number of the
genetic disorders that we would happen
to see so I mentioned a little bit
further on and as well about why that's
quite important and but we've also had
gotten more recently than the concept of
testing the genome and even the genome
trails where else
testing mom and dad on the kids I can
move forward
so I guess to reiterate a little bit and
what we're trying to achieve
to some degree anyway is a diagnostic
paradigm shift this looks like it's a
big power line shift in my little
diagram but it's actually not meant to
be quite as significant without my
experience we go on so in the early day
so let's say back in 2010 and the notion
was I'm saying 2010 but I really need no
this is the way I operate and I connect
the right line we take a history we
perform the examination of a patient we
do a number of investigations that are
led by our chemical examination by the
history and come up with a differential
diagnosis and then we apply additional
paths to confirm or realize various of
those differential diagnoses and then
hopefully end up within hobbyists where
a diagnosis is confirmed I mean if the
diagnosis is unconfirmed well we go back
and we iterate on it until we come up
with a good idea
this living may take a long time it can
take sometimes many many years before
you actually come up with an answer if
you come up with an answer at all so
what we're really trying to move then
towards in the more modern era is
this concept of where we left shift the
genome that some targeted genetic
testing we have up here
what will this make up earlier in the
process so when the patient is being
assessed put them in early and this may
not even be in a specialist genetic
Center this may be in there a new PD
African tour by their primary care
practitioner or by the attending in the
eb department when they when the patient
comes in the genome can be a thing that
is that is dumb and then we can then
move on to saying can we find the
diagnosis of up stage once we have that
then move on to a more thorough and
explication or noting done in the
phenotype and then integrating all those
different data sources together so we've
got something really memory forward with
I have mentioned it's not quite as
simple as this and there's there quite a
few complications as we go through and
this is an interesting comment from
Francis Collins who as most of you will
know and let the human genome project
and they run up to the United of the of
the first human genome and these a
pleasing very well positioned I think to
to make a lot of these games before they
felt balls but over the course of the
next few decades DNA sequencing will
lead to each beings genome being
sequenced and used to shape a lifetime
of personalized strategies for disease
prevention detection and treatment and
those in 2014 and I think this is still
maybe slightly controversial but I I
feel we're having an interaction and I
think their number of reasons quite up
would be a good thing but there are a
number of cap number of caveats that we
have to apply to that and we need to be
careful not to over promise and
particularly not to over promise too
early so there are certain things that
we may be able to share with the genomes
things that we'll be able to do and
there's some things that we won't be
able to do even even if everything works
out in the very best possible case so I
think we need to be careful what we say
and the nearly other side lives a lot of
questions as you know there's metabolic
screening that goes on at the moment
with say with me and it's to try and
detect conditions that can be treatable
if we're caught early so things that are
going to be very problematic for that
child and I'm sometimes fearful for a
child as we move forward if we can
detect them early and treat them early
we may be able to avoid those problems
arising so things like phenylketonuria
would be cleaner would be the most
common example of that but there are
other conditions such as cystic fibrosis
and many many others that are
phonetically diagnosed with early you
can get a good management strategy in
place and make daddy look much better
for that child so the question is really
if we take genome sequencing to replace
Nia natal screening ok they come up
things like you know what's the puzzle
predictive value of they the tasks that
we're going to use so if we if we apply
genomics to that can we say for certain
what bird and what we're going to find
what they tell me what's the cost of
that and careful on some terms and it
may will be the genome screening might
be in a position to replace those other
tests or maybe it might have to
complement them ok as I will go to work
and then one of the ethical and legal
aspects of finding sequence information
in minutes so the classic example of
this is if we test a child which has DNA
and we find a brca1 mutation well that's
the condition that the child is not
called a developed until much later in
life if if at all Emin I'm hopefully not
obviously what's going on vacations down
to the rest of the family because and if
we find a brca1 mutation and child it's
most likely they've come for one of the
other parent so somebody enough family
there's potentially at risk so how do we
then push that forward and well how does
that affect the rights of the child
themselves to have privacy of their own
genetic information whenever they're old
enough to be an autonomous novel so
there's
there's no Pollyanna and solution to
this this is a it's a tricky enough
problem we had a very interesting
experience over a number of years a back
in the early years of this particular
decade in the DVD study and this was
obtained the largest excellent study
that was carried out but it's been
superseded since then because things are
moving fast it actually has been one of
the most useful studies that we've been
involved in at a very very long time to
operationalize genomics at the routine
clinical level so this was a fascinating
study and or both operationally from the
organization point of view and also in
the results that we got back out of it
but for a political point of view we
were able to engage all of the genomic
or genetic medicine centers in the UK
and Ireland together to get a more or
less complete picture of a of our
islands and this is what particularly
exciting and so as you can Thailand
collaboration a 28 centers and including
the Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute in
Cambridge in England and they're able to
kind of next-generation sequencing on a
large number of kids reader we end for
12,000 back in the day but then we
actually end up with 14,000 which is
quite good so fourteen thousand exomes
extracted largely from saliva and from
blood samples and these were largely
trios so again mum dad and child and we
fight exome sequencing we apply to raise
and different a genomic techniques to
these samples to see what can right now
the interesting thing I guess about this
study is that we went in with very very
few hypotheses so we weren't going and
listened to beauty of excellent
screening as as you know we weren't
going anything right we want to look at
specifically a blessing or you want to
look at Ibis orders or skin disorders
this was an unselected crucification
who were and identified by the local
genetics
Center as being kids we had very
significant problems of one form or
another some kids are gonna have
developmental delay some Cajun have
birth defects and severe cardiac
malformations and other kids are gonna
have metabolic disorders that we have
until we get to the bottom of and
seizures nots and lots of different
things and what we try to do was
systematically encode the phenotypes
phenotype is everything in any of these
a investigations I will mention a little
bit other thousand move on but get those
phenotypes and then find out what
happens next
where do we clearly go to next and with
exome sequencing testing all the genes
not coding rate or another non-coding
regions and coding regions of these
genes and requires not galliston and i
should mention this was well supported
to trust our science study from the
Wellcome Trust from the health
Innovation Challenge from that the
English department of health and also
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute which
because I would be infrastructure for
putting it all together and the National
Institute for Health Research in England
so as no Maryland we kind of managed to
get onto this without having to spend
too much to have money that's that's
fine so once mentioned one of the cases
of excited that we put into the DDD
study and to really use her as a bit of
an example as to why this is such a
useful approach and so this girl at the
time she was five and I have been seeing
her for a number of years in my clinic
because we couldn't really figure out
what was going on with her she was the
first child of non-constant with his
parents and no particular family has
trade note and everyone else in the
family was absolutely fine but from the
very early neonatal period she was
extremely developmentally delayed and
should very very little muscle tone on
her MRI grams count showed that she had
very large doctor goes bilaterally with
reveille a symmetrical
and although she has structurally normal
eyes she was unable to see because she
had cortical visual impairment and very
limited communication and quite
dysmorphic facial features as you can
see there in the photograph rather old
chip nose and smallish chin small might
quite abnormal hair portals at the back
of her head as well so in addition to
her developmental delay she also have
seizures and this is a little girl
really who required an awful lot of
management from both the medical point
of view to keep her and keep her well
and keep her going as best we could but
also from the diagnostic point of view
we've a an electronic system an organ
arm that allows us to get a regional
view across our region of all the tasks
that are carried out on patients and
other chemical adders and other chemical
pointment and another different lab
tests are done so when I put this slide
together and this is a slide that was
taken from another presentation that was
about a year at a bit 9 but at that
stage she had 59 requests for energy and
this will include chest x-rays skull
x-rays MRI brain scans MRI spine and
upper science also and we call it kind
of 591 novel quests on the middle of the
moor and the rover about stage 100
dictated clinical documents in her
electronic medical record she's a number
of other investigations have mentioned
the MRIs but also biopsies number
punctures and electrophysiological tests
as well so if you are not up and you
look at the amount of ins the financial
costs of us leaving aside the imposition
on the child herself and on the family
and the discomfort and the distress and
the time is take up what they're talking
about Candace items of UK Pines
tens of thousands of dollars of tasks
that work area like to
turn to the stage where ordinarily would
say right we're ready to the gene test
right nine and so we put her into the
DVD study when this is the kind of thing
that happened with in the DVD study so
it started off and run the called the
exomes so it sequence all the other
genes and we find there's about 20,000
different variants within all her jeans
and but 400 of these we were able to say
where those are rare disease or rare
gene changes there they're likely to
have a functional effect on the protein
but we can then pull up down filters
down further until we get Dino stage
where we get a few of the exactly they
may have some degree of clinical
relevance at that stage you really do
need to candle input from your regional
genetic center so our DSS regional
genetic Center and your regional
genetics hunter team to see whether they
match up and on average what we find is
that we get a of a couple of if you're
lucky and the half the kids we couldn't
find any yet but then you've got to get
a couple of variants that we'd say this
could plausibly be connected with
whatever they and the condition is in
this child and when we did this with
this particular little girl we find the
cheese got mutated a mutation rate
specific mutation here's our here and in
this photograph and to the right
specific mutation r1 at 2 W and this
gene PPP to r1 a and this is a gene
that's known to interact with another
gene called PPP to our 5b and this is an
intra set of signaling Gina - it's an
intracellular kenya's so it's involved
in signaling cascade within themselves I
don't quite know I always ties together
yet but we're working on that but we do
know about the particular amino acids
they say these ones down here these
these for kids of the hardness and the
bottom part of the side of the right
all hop mutations that are very very
close together within the PPP to our
1:18 again these kids as well and adults
with mutations in pppt RFID again have
mutations that are clustered within a
very very small range of amino acids and
what happen is these two proteins
actually come together they dimerize on
the area which they kiss together is a
importance the areas and corresponds to
the amino acids so what we've got is
effectively a new syndrome that is a is
connected to this particular signaling
cascade and this is been extremely
useful in was funny because we were able
to tell for example that this is a de
novo mutation so we know what it and
happened in her alone and that the risk
to other family members if the parents
have another child the risks are very
low and it's not zero but it's very low
but the risk of to other members of the
family is no higher than the general
population so that's a very reassuring
thing with the mentalities telling
families quite a number of patients with
this were find in the DVD study and
likely to other patients with PPP to our
site D within our own cohort of patients
we had over 700 patients included in to
the overall 14,000 and we find two other
patients so far with PT PT RFID but
there's still a lot of analysis to be
done on other cases so I'm expecting to
find more of these I think we're gonna
find us probably quite a and we'll an
under-recognized
new genetic syndrome and the family have
had quite a hard time coming to terms of
the fact that we don't have a and the
endlessness of mahalo nitro a person you
know touches so we call it PP PT r1a
doesn't exactly roll off the tongue so
it does cause problems with families but
has it needs to light these families to
start getting in contact with each other
and to start sharing their experience
and maybe further down the line when we
know more about this mechanism we may be
able to come up with treatments or make
life better for these kids
so another case to stay to extend the
example of this is a little girl that we
had investigated very very extensively
and non consequence counts but this
little girl was extremely hyper taught
and very very irritable from birth she's
great arched back and straight stiff and
we couldn't really work out she was
having seizures or not which is very
unstable in general but she went on she
got a little bit over and she developed
these very disco movements it became
clear that the choose appreciatin quake
that of what was going on around her
but she had very very severe problems in
communicating what was going on
and herself and know and the fact of
gross motor skills out of all the
pictures so severely disabled by these
dystonic movements and these this we
felt was given rise to quite a degree of
frustration in this little girl um
certainly a lot of frustration and her
family as well so all our tests and this
would be a very common and finding in
genetics is that we do a lot of tests
and claim nothing but is pointing us
towards the diagnosis systems on this
causes more delay and time this family
were really really keen to have another
child but very very scared of having
another child I had told them at the
time when I felt this was probably going
to be a de novo mutation in some gene or
other and the risk of recurrence is
going to be very low but I couldn't say
that for sure I said it could it could
be recessive it could be and a condition
of maybe my diversity of occurrence of
one for so where do you take it from
there
well we've put her into the DD study and
actually it took quite a while to find
the result but we've got mutation and
this gene maybe a 5 which is involved
and this say they couldn't like modify
our pathway and in conjunction with
colleagues in Finland and elsewhere we
were able to find a number of kids who
have mutations in this particular gene
this EBA a 5 gene which nonetheless
assess of disorder does the wall
mutation mom's government other
mutations is a compound heterozygote for
mutations within you da fi one of it's
an oxygen unit of action completely and
the other one decreases the level very
very significantly we move a nice if you
not good you know completely those nice
embryos in my examples they don't
survive so we feel that this is a hypo
morphic Ally of UVA five that is a
lineman child to survive but survive
with quite severe problems and this is
tricky obviously then for the family
because we know I know this is a woman
for personal records so now is it not a
big piece of information of thumb you
have to then take on board and we have
of course supposedly we do know what the
mutations are and we've got the
potential for prenatal diagnosis
potentially pre-implantation diagnosis
as well so that's something the family
are currently weighing up and seeing and
what way they want to and go to proceed
with this very very caring family very
loving family but they find it very
useful to again be able to put in
contact with other families and similar
problems and also to to be able to have
a diagnosis that they can talk about and
we can then get the management sort of
like so it's done improve them and just
a bit of an overview of a DVD in general
and I mentioned the hypothesis free
nature of the study this is a paper that
we got very recently in nature and
looking at the genes that we find
mutated within daily the number of times
or a mutated I'm using the what we know
about the likelihood of finding a
mutation just anywhere the genome we're
able to work out what's the likelihood
of this particular gene causing a
developmental problem versus versus not
and so separately we find within the
exact database from the Broad Institute
and but there are certain genes that you
just don't get away with having a
mutation but normal people just don't
commutations in these particular genes
so when we find mutations in this group
of patients whom you already know assess
hypothesis free as lying a little bit we
kids that we know how to severe
developmental disorder so if we find a
mutation in those children in these
particular genes that don't tolerate
mutations very well then it becomes more
likely a priori that this is
contributing to their developmental
today so a number of genes were the top
scores and here for example our 1b isn't
genes responsible for a condition called
Cotham Sarris syndrome which night turns
out to be one of the most common
conditions that we see in genetics and
even but ten years ago I recall the knee
of the conference where we were
seriously considering the possibility
that Collins has syndrome didn't really
exist as a syndrome but was just a
collection of different things we might
know that they are 1b I'm genes are
associated with r1 they are responsible
for this particular condition now it's
much more common than we thought before
icardi 11 in the gene that's responsible
for a condition called kdg syndrome and
this is a syndrome but again used to be
regarded as being very rare and we
couldn't really diagnose it we never saw
it
in genetics and once we find the gene
and find out what we should have been
living for in the first test we started
to realize that actually this is quite a
common condition and the problem really
was that we just didn't have the
chemical reference models to look back
and find it so we've never been able to
diagnose quite a number of kids with kdg
syndrome families indeed with KBG
syndrome on the basis of a knowing more
of it what this syndrome actually
involves I'm assuming applies the
numbers are several other conditions at
the if you can see there so I would
recommend looking up our paper in nature
I like to think it's been quite well
listen them quite well argh you can
quickly put together but I think it
shows the power of using a exome
analysis and by extension genome
analysis in this group of kids who have
got these severe problems but again the
problem is that this is hobbling towards
the end of your your diagnostic conflict
so you know can we can you do better
than up and this is just a little shot
of a lot of the pain that were involved
in the DPD project if I find looking
bunch of folks I think they all are and
as you all know as well knew nothing
ever happens anymore and
science from certainly not in Madison
fine individual effort that's always
involving many many people they're all
working together and in this particular
case has been the nicest team of people
I've ever been fortunate enough to work
with so I'm very grateful that them
included in your consortium yeah so
Clark in 2012 after the London Olympics
are then Prime Minister is this fellow
here and then going to Vegas little
comment on our physical situation of the
possibly camp decided that as our legacy
from the 2012 Olympics we have set a
number of big signature product projects
and one of those was the hundred
thousand genomes project so this is to
go across the UK initially an immense
book with ninety joined in from Northern
Ireland as well and we all Scotland was
running soon to to get a hundred
thousand genomes sequence on people with
cancers and with rare diseases and the
idea here would be to they just sheer
force of genomic numbers and the
processing of the data to find out new
treatments for these conditions under
understand them better so visually to
make kickstart precision medicine within
the UK national health system so that's
that's the plan and that was currently
underway and with recruitment quit
number of several thousand people
throughout know that several thousand
genomes across the UK and northern man
we were a little bit behind be a behind
of time so we we've only very recently
joined and we've got our first patients
starting to come through that nice and
with no results to report from the
hundred thousand but we're going there
the model however is still very
redshifted so we're still doing the same
thing where the disorders are being
nominated by our folks within the
National Health Service and also the
universities
specific disorders so again we're
starting with hypothesis for gathering
loads and loads of data with their very
tight data model around most of these
nominated conditions so it's not quite
at the stage where we're really left
shifting it to this more hypothesis free
model but I think we're going to need in
the long term however the good news
about it is it allows us to learn
techniques for extracting DNA at
lifestyle and more systematically
different things that we're actually
looking for and things are starting to
come through from not really really
quite well and alongside that have been
some very exciting developments having
stateside and accompany my love name is
Stephen Kingsmore I became in countless
buddies night in San Diego developed
with his team a process whereby if a
baby was born he was extremely ill and
they didn't know what was going on with
us then within 50 hours so two days they
were able to get a preliminary genomic
genome-wide full genome sequencing
report into the hands of the clinicians
who are looking after that daily
potentially really really important so
it goes back to Francis Collins previous
a comment of it and sequencing the
genomes of duties in this case these
entities are very variable and so we
notice a problem under challenge of
making a diagnosis so what we can
Kingsmore on this team were able to show
was that this is in principle we can
turn around the genome on the full
analytics associated with that and get a
diagnosis or at least the first pitch of
diagnosis within 50 hours that's pretty
impressive and I mean the scum and
science from Science Translational
Medicine money alone PI magazine at one
stage and because I was blown away by
this say it was technical say it's very
very exciting
the problem is operationalizing love
this involved many many people coming
together on
to be working running the clock to get
that turnaround in 50 RS so it's 50 RS
in terms of time start here and here
it's much much more than 50 personal
hours to get that to get that through so
how do we operationalize on how do we
make that real coming back to the
hundred flesh and genomes project this
gentleman a got a diagnosis and him and
his family for a mutation in the INF 2
gene looks which was causing and his his
arena theater this progressive renal
theater so again so many useful things
with us family because we know that the
problems with this particular type of
renal failure can be offset by
aggressively treating their hypertension
I'm gonna making sure that we're
monitoring their lingo function very
carefully so we can stay of these the
arena theater often these patients and
we prevent prevent the need to
transplant in some of these patients as
well if we can identify them early and
so that's a useful example of say of 100
dollars actually starts in both so we're
getting there
2016 was the green things going to get
it was a kind of weird year I don't
think
then you stay outside on us and a UK
site will be very well aware of us and
when certain events are probably in
November 2016 I had the pleasure of
segment with responses very nice people
up near the Lebanese border and Israel
and they following your election result
we have to change our route quite
significantly because through a bit of
activity has happened up there and
Austin's immune response to things but
in a results the way we we feel about
what's happening in our world at a wider
level that is no doubt that we are
making progress things are coming along
in a very very useful way and you know
sometimes you look around you think the
world's scariest weird and we're
approaching things that we are not
familiar with and that's exactly how
many of our families and doctors and we
feel about the developments within
genomics so we still got a look at this
exciting technology that's come through
night but still very ad hoc if you want
to get your genome sequence
there's no doubt about it but it's
better that you are seen in a very
highly specialized unit and with lots of
funds I have got very high-level
specialists who can get the entire
genome sequencing or exome sequencing
project so we're in the big academically
nuts then specialized research project
again as I've mentioned before and keep
mentioning this always happens towards
the end of the diagnostic process now
you could say the reason what happens at
the end of the diagnostic process is
because by the time you find your
diagnosis standard definition matters
and if your your diagnostic process but
the point still remains that we've
already spent a lot of money I've had a
lot of effort a lot of time spent before
we get to that stage and this gentleman
here is gem of mine professor Sir John
Byrne who it's from newcastle upon tyne
in england and he came over to Belfast
again it's a very interesting lecture on
the rise and fall of genomic medicine
before that is coming easily you know
some that before that was look scary
hopefully mean by genomic medicine
falling and caused a little bit of
consternation back to the start but John
was able to explain this quite clearly
what he meant was when genomics becomes
medicine there's no longer needing it
doesn't needi qualify anymore doesn't
need to be called genomic medicine
because it's part of medicine the idea
is that we get to knowledge an early
sphere to cut down these unnecessary
investigations and costs would get
patients on to a defined management plan
we avoid this damage from ill-judged
interventions and this makes a lot this
does resonates with me so much
particularly because a lot of my little
patients end up getting needles and
things stuck on them I mean that's
chopped out of them for biopsies and
things when we could make those
diagnosis a lot better if we had the
right processes in place
and I've mentioned it aligned with
families to plan the annoying these
recurrent risks and then also forbade
very treatment these are these are
markers that are coming through and I
think they're getting really really used
to this so you know it's no longer seen
as being a particularly incredible thing
so if we're going to get this kind of
thing to work if we're going to get the
genome black identity the population can
we learn any lessons from where with
being before an answer I think is yes
and very recently as well because it's
not that long ago it's been about 10
years ago when CGH microarrays to look
for very small chromosomal deletions and
duplications
well again things that were ordered by
clinical geneticists or by a very
specialized specialists rather would be
available to a two or three
pediatricians or and then accessible to
patients obviously to take them off the
street or at their initial time of
referral this dogleg is a research tool
they were very expensive so how to
control the access to these tests quite
a lot just for financial reasons in
enlightened sense that of course you
know expensive tests can't possibly be
economically viable and the cost is
obviously comes I'm with microarrays as
well when I retain and we get them
ordered by our pediatricians directly in
fact I don't even see a child anymore
with developmental delay and we haven't
but usually if we haven't carried out a
CGH microarray and so these are
frontline tasks that it's done for
investigation of developmental delay
before they ever come near the
geneticist and we still do find that
there are a number of reasons why you
still would need expert interpretation
so for example there are lots of copy
number variations that we find within
kids Benford for developmental delay it
could be completely denying so knowing
whether they're inherited or not becomes
becomes very well
so we've got an example of a high that
can work and the question is what do we
actually want what do we as commissions
and what their patience and guess what
there are health commissioner's and
various other people want to do we don't
want to turn people into dinosaurs and
that would be C but we know we do know
what we want we want to have sequencing
available relatively cheaply and within
the National Health Service in the UK
it's a nationalized system so we're
great conscious of costs we can't really
defray those by passing them on terror
and consumers other insurers we want to
happen early in the process as early as
possible
maybe not the me enable stage but at
least when we know there's a potential
problem that we have two tiers up and we
want to have a rapid access to knowledge
base we've got they will make sense of
this information that's coming through
and they know it's base I also mean
access experts we're going to help us
out on this to living on to those
questions that we've mentioned before
get on to those treatment plans get
multidisciplinary teams involved and
then also got other patients in the
whether public involved in doing these
things as well so how do we make all
this happen we don't let it go as one
thing I feel that we are having this
gauge again agreeing with closest
columns to a large extent is that we
will be doing a genome at a very early
stage but we've got to have in some way
of working like what we do we've got to
decide that the genome itself isn't a
test
we've gotta move away from this idea of
thinking of genes and gene test or gene
investigations or I go usually make gene
investigations being a test genetic
information has to be seen as being part
of the background information but
applies to these children are novels
it's about that should be part of the
simple background stuff along with
everything else that we we make our
chemical decisions on this stuff so all
the other data that we have we have to
interpret genomics with thought I'm
basically using a resource to
interrogate not just during the
diagnostic process but actually during
the life of location we may acquire this
data once
get into a computer analyzable form and
then continue to ask questions over
there as we as we move for the patient's
life that's going to be a big challenge
there are things that privacy where it
is stored I've mentioned against and
mental findings or the chemically
actionable findings as well as we move
forward so what do we do in that
situation I'll say that's going to be
the challenge one thing we do have to do
I think is recognize that we have over
the years developed this referral
mechanism to get between a certain age
regardless lower levels of care up to
more specialized levels of care and we
have broken that mechanism it doesn't
function very well at least the long
waiting lists it leads to you and a
bunch in between multiple different
specialists before the diagnosis was
needed so we've got to learn to find
ways of blurring these lines between the
currently be market the different
specialisms we have to be very open to
being much more multidisciplinary in
case discussion often before we end up
the seeing them super nerd in the UK I
do quite notice like in the u.s. from
the UK basically the default thing is if
I'm a doctor and I'm a questionable
patient and refer the patient on to my
colleague in say neurology or oncology
or something and they will then answer
remember question i that have happened
to be once they see the patient in
instrumentation bag not takes a lot of
time with a lot of inconvenience for the
patient to come up people have a bunch
around numerous different people we need
to find different ways of us asking
those questions I'm showing those
questions are unli isn't with our
colleagues
I'm with the patient as well to get that
information to flow and go be much more
rational to their investigations and
think what am I doing here is it going
to actually help the patient and get
possibly the very core aspect of
medicine sometimes we forget this how
will this help first do no harm
I will this help
and the big challenge is going to be
particularly for complicated pieces of
information like genomic information how
to bring the patient into the discussion
and bring them to a level where they're
they're able to interact excessively
with narrow data because this is the
patient's data and personally I think
very strongly that this is information
that they are entitled to under they
should have an our job is to guide them
through that and to help them to to
navigate so it's always
freeing the data and they can surely
move things forward so back to our
frozen theme and mention my a culture of
metaphors a little bit here this is our
patient who is sitting here surrounded
by all different forms of information
that we can gather under genome as part
of that pedigree is part of the genetic
information is part of that so what
we're seeing here is and I guess my
conceptualization of instead of doing
tests we're trying to just gather
together as much of the information as
possible this is my very talented
multidisciplinary team and all with
different skills definitely have other
needs and different aptitudes
everybody's get something to bring to
the party here of course the patient
themselves has perhaps the most
important role to plan the whole thing
so it's about this multidisciplinary
disciplinarity some way I learned to say
it up how do we leverage that an
internal into proper patient benefit of
us earlier stage in the process as we
possibly can
I think we can do that but we have to
break that referral mechanism properly
we've got to start asking our College
questions there's a fantastic piece of
technology that they was developed a
while back and it's called telephone and
I got one of these I'm mostly colleagues
with one of these and what they can do
is they can ring me up and they can ask
me questions like I'm going to come up
and ask them questions and we have to
put aside our pride a little bit
were more Cain and Abel unwilling to do
that is really really important that we
did it's going to become more important
as companies that 23andme and other
companies become a involved in the
business of doing genetic analysis for
our patients as people go forward and
this is mine here I hope you will find
that it might relevance unfortunately
but I'm happy to be 2.6 percent
Neanderthal and these are my great-great
grandparents and we were a very small
holding farmers in editorial in Ireland
we all come from somewhere I guess we'll
go in someone the question is where it's
all gonna take us and I hope I've been
able to convince you that we're at Las
Vegas is away from our little ivory
towers and into a much more collegiate
and collaborative environment of remote
interpreters data but the big thing I
guess is that's left just the genome
gets done earlier in the process and see
where that leads us thank you very much
dr. McKee thank you so much for that
informative and wonderful presentation
we want to begin our Q&A segment a
reminder of how audience members can
communicate with us questions and
answers can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left if we are
unable to get to your questions due to
time constraint dr. McKee will be
answering submitted questions yet email
so let's start with our first question
an audience member would like to know
where do most of your referrals come
from
okay we're really most of our referrals
come from let's say we get referrals
from everywhere
so eh sometimes when babies are born if
their birth defects will get a referral
from the neonatal yet and - immediately
once the baby's born or it may be later
on us if child a child has been find to
have developmental delay we're going to
get a referral from pediatricians and a
time wrong with trying to get more and
more adult neurological conditions being
referred to us particularly adult
cancers so there's very very wide range
of conditions and more recently I
suppose some of the genes for dementia
we find as well we're getting patients
from care of the elderly specialist
being referred in as well so over the
number of years say something over the
past 15 years so we've seen our referral
rates really double it's coming from
right across the range a gas because and
you can affect people in in multiple
different ways basically every system of
the body any time of life so it really
is a bit of clearinghouse for conditions
but we can't we have work out other ways
but I think particularly northern around
here we have a good relationship with
most of our refers we're a relatively
small health economy with 1.8 million
people and burn a reasonably confined
area so we know most of the people here
referring in to us at a day and a very
closely level so it works well as a unit
so hold on answer the question thank you
so much you're very wonderful question
you talked mostly about genetic
syndromes is there a water cancer for
genomic sequencing or other disorders
so yeah that's a good question and I did
mention it briefly there about day about
the counselor side of things as well and
also in the 100 thousand genomes project
and indeed in some of the other research
projects that we're getting with we're
getting with counselors too and both
pediatric and adult the loan counselors
is actually very very interesting
because one of the things we try to do
is we want to compare the genome of the
person in the healthy state so typically
we'd get that from the blood stream and
we want compare that with the genome in
the actual tumor because cancer very
often is a genetic disease up a sale
level so if we can work out what they
genetic changes are within the cancer
then the potential is that we can direct
the the treatment that that person would
receive towards they have some specific
weakness but we could identify within
the tumor so finding cures weakness is
is the big thing when best examples of
that is a gene called a Matar which
controls growth of cells it's involved
in a signaling pathway both the two
genes at PSC one PSC two genes involved
in tuberous sclerosis were quite
successful and episodes of treating
brain tumors in cage with tuberous
sclerosis with drugs are specifically
targeted towards that particular pathway
not an forging so to Weldon fielder we I
think we will lighten and not ever ever
further so it'll get bigger
we have time for one more question from
our audience members dr. McKie apart
from gene therapy like CRISPR cast 9 are
there other ways we might treat genetic
condition yeah and I think that they are
cute eyes in brain very well so it will
start in the last question there and
there are areas where if we complete
what the gene is or the rather of
genetic mechanism is for a tumor of
genetic disease or whatever and we're
not necessarily stuck with trying to fix
that particular gene or that particular
pathway and we may be able to look
downstream from that pathway or upstream
the influence it otherwise so for
example I mentioned there with tuber
sclerosis on the TSC won't ESC two genes
that then involve the pathway that goes
through this common molecule in the cell
called Ant or and enter stops from
mammalian target of rapamycin and
rapamycin was cattle it was originally
find in soil samples and bacteria from
soil samples from Easter Island Easter
islands Rapa Nui so hence rapamycin and
what we were able to find was that a lot
of the symptoms of cheerless neurosis
which may involve a little lesions on
the skin and epilepsy developmental
today and these really quite problematic
and very dangerous cysts in the kidneys
as well as brain tumors a lot of these
symptoms can get a lot better if we
block that gene so nori the tsc1 PSC two
genes there Jose the block and heart if
we can find another way of blocking aunt
or then a lot of the dime stream effects
from cheerio cirrhosis pending little
bit better
we're not curing the condition
necessarily but we can
have a very useful clinical effect on
indeed that's what we find
so using small molecules larger
molecules different ways of treating and
these conditions are in this writing
style things so for example I'm creating
an hypercholesterolemia looking these
statins but a lot of times well we use
dietary restrictions plantations dying
and similar to some of the genetic forms
of that but let's say we can use a
ketogenic diet to very rather pay
control the seizures so knowing the
mechanism helps us to to work out which
a which treatments are likely to work
better so I think it's a very very
exciting area that knowing what a thing
is it may not tell you immediately how
to fix it but can give you some very
very good ideas we need creative people
within genetics and genomics to think
outside the box I'm certainly excited
the gene - there are other ways of
dealing with these things so the
question thank you dr. McKeon thank you
to our audience members dr. McKee do you
have any final comments you'd like to
share with our audience today
and yeah thanks thanks I also have
really enjoyed presenting to you I think
Bob Ritz is a fantastic a endeavour and
you can able to get this this
information I can much lighter audience
know would not only be a be necessarily
attending a physical conference I think
it's a good thing I guess they the
comment and one of hope people would
take from my talk is that you know we've
got so much it's really really great
technology and they're you know I've
seen some very very impressive talks I'm
really what I want to do because I'm
just a Phoenix elf scholars being not
lonely little a pediatrician running
around the wards in the Children's
Hospital and trying to help my patients
as they pretty much come in through the
door and some of the really good stuff
that we can do and the very high
technology of God we've got to use that
in a human way to make a difference for
our patients um particularly times of
the essence we've got get these things
done quickly because the sooner we can
get a patient or a family to stage where
they at least got the diagnosis and
where we can start to take another
breath and think rationally about how we
treat this condition then the better and
it's it's an exciting time to be in the
field of genetics and genomics and but I
really think things are going to move
forward so things are gonna be science
fiction night and I don't think it's
going to necessarily too long before
their science reality so just wanna
thank the audience for the four brands
and they hope everything goes well thank
you
thank you so much dr. McKee and thank
you for your dedication here Phil I'd
like to also thank lab rates for making
to the educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand you mean until August 2017
keep an eye out for an email from on
route to learning new window webcast
will be available for replay we
encourage you to board that announcement
to your colleagues with victory flag
right into the joining us and we hope
same come back next time goodbye